President Trump did the right thing by
walking away from the Vietnam summit
without giving in to Kim's demands for
sanctions relief that is according to a
former North Korean official his
comments come as the president's top
diplomat is putting a positive spin on
the abrupt end of the conference senior
foreign affairs correspondent Greg
Powell Khan has that story
tonight from Seoul South Korea Kim
jong-un meeting with top vietnamese
officials today a day after the North
Korean leaders summit with President
Trump in Hanoi broke down on a stop off
in the Philippines Secretary of State
Bob Mayo still sounded positive in South
Korea an offer to mediate my
administration will closely
communicating cooperate with the United
States and North Korea so as to help
their talks reach a complete settlement
by any means
according to longtime North Korean
career diplomat and now defector Taeyang
halt speaking with Fox News President
Trump was correct in rejecting the
demand by the north to lift up billions
of dollars worth of sanctions in
exchange for shutting down just one
nuclear facility president Trump was
absolutely right that he cannot give up
these sanctions
unless Kim Jong Hwan are promises even
further denuclearization office day said
Trump was also right when he singled out
other nuclear sites he wanted Kim to
dismantle but the man who now lives with
guards under assassination threats in
Seoul near his former home which he
calls a land of modern slaves says as
long as the clever and merciless kim
jonghwan is in power the best president
Trump can do is contain the nuclear evil
nuclear weapons are the last resort of
each kim giman can rely on to continue
his control over North Korea so do you
think he would ever give up the nuclear
weapon no no no not at all not at all
defector tey does say he's positive
about North Korea's future with more
information and changes among the people
the currents
system and its leader can't last but
that change could take years in the
meantime he says we've got to keep the
nuclear lid on Shannon all right Greg
pankot in Seoul South Korea thank you